we have a problem in this country and
it's called the female voter and nobody
likes to say it but it's true the female
voter oftentimes will respond
emotionally to these things who couldn't
stand Trump women women couldn't stand
Trump they couldn't stand his Twitter
account they couldn't stand and I myself
acknowledge that I even had that reflux
reflex at times I would look and be like
oh stop doing that I did so because I
felt it was counterproductive to his
policy it was distracting I knew that he
was aggravating women I was like don't
aggravate them with a Twitter feed let
them support you with your policy but
there is a segment here that we're
talking about and that is women that
will respond emotionally to the language
of the left meaning what Tom was talking
about going after abortion rights making
this an emotional debate if the left
wants to win this next election they
have to make this emotional and they
have to Target women so I beckon women
all the time don't vote based on emotion
vote based on policy